في ظهوره المفاجئ الرقابه لون صيني
الاوساط العسكريه والسياسيه في واشنطن
وزاد من توتر العلاقات المتارجحه اصلا بين
الولايات المتحده والصين البنتاجون اعلن
عن متابعه طائرات عسكريه للبالون اما
البيت الابيض فاعلن تاجيل زياره وزير
الخارجيه انطوني بلينكل للصين المقررات
بعد ايام
هو الرد العسكري الامريكي او في هذه
الحاله عدم الرد سمعنا تقارير تتحدث ان
الرئيس بصفته القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه طلب اسقاط البلو والبنتاغو رفض
البالون الصيني هو بالون واختبار لاداره
بايدن
قررت تريث قبل اسقاطه مع التاكيد على
قابليته على المناوره وشدد على ان العمل
مستمر مع القياده المركزيه الشماليه
للدفاع الجوي لكشف المزيد عن المنطاد من
دون الاشاره الى طبيعته وكيفيه دخوله
الاجواء الامريكيه
هذا البالون ذو طبيعه تجسسيه الاقمار
الصناعيه تاخذ صورا ادق ولكن البالون
يستكشف المكان بدقه اعلى فهو يرصد الحراره
ونوع الهواء المحيط بالهدف لجمع المعلومات
حوله
البالون كانت له عصداء سياسيه ايضا حيث
سارع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب للمطالبه
باسقاطه وكذلك كان راي المشرعين
الامريكيين في الكونجرس الذين اعتبروا ان
استخدام الصين لمنقاد المراقبه انتهاك
واضح لسياده الولايات المتحده وسلامه
اراضيها وذهبوا الى مطالبه وزير الخارجيه
انطاني بلنكر بالغاء رحلته
لدخول بالون مختص بالابحاث والطقس المجال
الجوي الامريكي من دون قصد خاصه وان هذه
الحادثه تاتي في وقت حساس بالنسبه
للعلاقات المتوتره بين القوتين الدوليتين
وبالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه التي تحاول
تطويق النفوذ الصينيه المتوسع في عده
مجالات تقنيا عسكريا واقتصاديا ريتا
سليمان العربيه واشنطن